las caravanas migrantes van en camino a
volverse endémicas en México 160
americanos y haitianos salieron este
viernes de la ciudad mexicana sureña
Tapachula con el objetivo de llegar a
Estados Unidos o qué
los migrantes denuncian el
incumplimiento de las autoridades
mexicanas que según afirman no han
mandado ni los suficientes camiones de
traslado ni las visas humanitarias que
les habían prometido
[Música]
mexicanas anunciaron que comenzaron el
traslado de los migrantes para su
regularización
el Instituto Nacional de Migración
informa es que dio inicio al traslado de
personas extranjeras a diferentes
estados de México para comenzar su
proceso de regularización migratoria en
el país en paralelo a esta caravana
migrante el territorio mexicano ha sido
testigo de múltiples influjos
migratorios este año cerca de 190000
inmigrantes se han detectado entre enero
y septiembre tres veces más que en el
mismo periodo en 2020 y la oficina de
aduanas estadounidense reporto más de
1,7 millones de personas indocumentadas
en la frontera con México